The Joe Rogan experience.
Did I have to say archaeologists like
to insult me by calling me a pseudo
scientist?
I can't think of anything
more pseudoscientific than
the Clovis first doctrine,
which locked American archeology for
50 years in a particular framework,
which we now know was totally wrong.
Nothing good about it at all. Uh,
a complete mistake.
What I'm hoping the book will do in the
long run is that it will lead to more
attention being focused on the Americas.
This is a very neglected
area of the world. Uh,
as far as deep and ancient
archeology goes, I'm, it's,
the recent history of the Americas
has been relatively well studied,
but the deep and ancient history has
not been, has not been well studied.
And I think America is going to contain
revelations for us about our story and
about our past.
And I'm serious when I,
when I suggest that America is the most
plausible and the most likely homebase
for a lost civilization. If you're
going to propose a loss of realization,
you need, there are certain
preconditions. You need a,
you can't have it on a small island.
There's got to be a large land mass with
enormous resources and the ability for
population to grow and for those
resources to be, to be mobilized.
And what I suddenly realized,
you asked earlier why I,
why I started to write this book at all
is what the new evidence is pointing to
is that the Americas have
been wrongly neglected.
That here we have a giant continental
land mass with extraordinary resources
that has just been ruled out of
the story of human civilization.
But once we take account of the fact that
there was a giant cataclysm over North
America 12,000,
800 years ago,
and once we start looking as I do in
America before at the incredible deep
indepth similarities between,
for example,
the religious system of ancient
Egypt and the religious system of the
Mississippi Valley,
then you realize that you're into or
into a global mystery here and that the
answer to that mystery may not at all be
in the old world and may very much be,
uh, in the, in the Americas. See, it's
odd. I mentioned Manville earlier on.
It's kind of odd that we should find a,
what is essentially the
ancient Egyptian religion, uh,
manifesting in the symbolism of Mountville
the ascent to a Ryan that transit to
the Milky Way, the journey
along the Milky Way. Very,
these are very specific
and idiosyncratic ideas.
And what makes it doubly hard
is Mountville isn't that old.
Manville as a site is
about a thousand years old.
Ancient Egypt had already been
gone completely from the world, uh,
for at least 600 years
before Manville was created.
The end of ancient Egypt.
There's, there's Manville and uh,
w w w what we're looking at in the
foreground is mount B and we're looking at
mount a and the in the,
in the distance, um, and,
and the complete circle of mountains.
What,
what is odd about it is we find this
system of ancient Egyptian ideas in
Manville 500 years after ancient Egypt
has gone from the world. The Romans,
the Romans were the end of ancient
Egypt by 400 d ancient Egypt has gone.
Manville doesn't even exist then,
but 600 years later it is created and
it manifests the entire set of ancient
Egyptian ideas.
Clearly it did not get that as a result
of direct transmission from ancient
Egypt unless they were time travelers.
The only way I think it could have got
it is as a result of a legacy pass down
from a much earlier civilization that has
influenced and affected many different
parts of the world and the
characteristics of that civilization.
There's the shamanistic heart of it, the
use of altered states of consciousness.
The focus on those are amongst the reasons
that I would suggest that America is
the place that we should be looking and
the big mysteries are in the areas that
were so devastated at the end of the
last ice age up in the north of North
America, the channeled scab
lands in particular and
then the Mississippi Valley.
The whole story of the Mississippi Valley.
Yes,
Mountville is a thousand years old,
but then you can go back to
poverty point in Louisiana,
which is 2,700 years old.
You can go to Watson break in Louisiana,
which is 5,500 years old.
You can go to sites like Conley,
which are 8,000 years old.
The system keeps on going back and
disappearing back into time, and I,
I think the most fruitful new work on
exploring the origins of civilization is
going to occur counterintuitively
in the Americas,
the very last place on earth that
archeologists have ever thought to look.